wait you don't have time to make a play
ribs Reeves got to get it in in
three-point country it's to Ryan on its
way
[Applause]
I told you that's why he should be in
the game you need someone who can just
catch and let fly and I mean I mean
shown that it doesn't have to stay in
his hand very long they'll review it but
it looked like a good shot or a legal
shot to me
and shocked I am Matt Ryan come on
another look at all the screening that's
going on I just
I've seen a thousand two oh not a
thousand it's definitely going to count
there's time all over the clock I must
maybe I forgot to do a coach's Clinic
why are you worried about a screen
when you have a three-point lead with
one second to play Play On Top if they
go to the basket so be it the screen
should never come into play you play on
top of all the screens they playing
underneath then they feel like they have
to switch
unbelievable
live and learn
seen it all in the NBA we go to an extra
five minutes tied at 111.
[Applause]